let's say you were speaking to um a
let's say someone in their 20s they've
just graduated University maybe they've
tried a job for 6 months and they're
like screw the job like job's not for me
I want to become a
Creator what would you if you if you had
to give this person if you were their
like mentors and you you you were giving
them a road map what would be the road
map now that it's 2023 to succeed in the
Creator economy you have to buy the
course to find out you can't answer that
yeah I'll invoice you after no I'm
kidding um so as I look back on that I
think the one thing that we always agree
upon was that we went into um making the
Colin and smear Channel with being very
like um selfish creators which is
completely fine it's like here's what we
want to make yeah right here's what we
want but if you're if you want to be a
Creator then you have to be empathetic
towards the audience and we were not an
artist has no empathy to to the audience
right an artist paints something and
says this is what I wanted to paint I
don't care what you think about it
interpret it as you wish okay if you
want to be an artist that is a different
thing yeah if you want to be a Creator
you have to be empathetic towards the
audience there's a balance between what
you want to make what the audience wants
and what the platform wants there's
three things that make up you know what
you want to make what the audience wants
and what the platform wants yeah okay
that's something that we call content
Market fit is finding you know that that
right in the middle of that is content
Market fit what you want to make what
the audience wants to watch and what the
platform wants okay so let's say I'm
like you know I really want to be a
music YouTuber I love Kurt Schneider I
love that voice Avenue era of uh popular
song covers on YouTube and I want to I
want to make money on YouTube playing
guitar and singing songs and I'm and you
guys are my mentors how would How would
how how how would we be having that
conversation I would say if you want to
make money figure out another way to
make money to start I think that's one
of the biggest mistakes we made when we
started this YouTube channel was that we
did not really think about where money
would come from and we assumed that it
would come pretty immediately from this
new pursuit of creating YouTube videos
because we had just come from a
background in YouTube why wouldn't it we
kind of thought we understood how that
would work but it it made us make
choices that were based out of fear
taking different production projects and
things that took energy away from what
we were trying to put into this creative
Pursuit so I think if you love music and
you want to make money from it figure
out a different way to start to make
money from it so that you can just focus
on the creative side and when it comes
to the the video making side I the first
question I would ask you is who's the
audience oh I'd be like I don't know
like people who want covers of Ed Sharon
songs on YouTube okay and how much of
that is available to
them loads of people are doing Edge Shar
C so i' ask you to scan that right and
say okay cool now go study who else is
doing what you want to do yeah why are
they watching what's interesting about
it you like do they have to watch of
these in a row is that the culture of
this audience where else do they hang
out on the internet outside of um
YouTube and a lot of what we've learned
I would say over the past 12 years is
this process of studying audiences
because we are again we are part of the
equation but the audience is we're
playing ping pong with an audience right
that's what the internet is really great
at we throw something out the audience
reacts to it and we understand oh
interesting that's what you what you
guys like that's what you didn't like
okay let me try this oo okay now I just
learned something new about you guys so
creating being a creator for the
internet is a collaborative process with
the audience and so you have to deeply
before you embark on this journey Define
who you're speaking to and understand
them it's okay for that to evolve I
don't want to say that you have to put
yourself in like a very tight box in the
beginning but that's the first question
I would ask you is lead with who you are
speaking to why is it valuable to them
CU you are asking people to invest time
in your edar and cover so what's their
return on that investment how does it
differ from what someone else is
offering it's like somewhat similar to
just general entrepreneurship or
launching a product like is there enough
space for you in this market if you are
going to enter that market are you
different are you singular do you stand
out or are you
replaceable and a lot of times you're
not going to you should think about it
upfront and you should figure that out
but a lot of times it's going to come
from starting m but I do think sometimes
people would get Leaps and Bounds ahead
if they were more aware of the market
they were entering or the space before
they did it hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye-bye